today at 12 o'clock lunchtime we took
full control of bakmut the operation to
take full control of backward lasted for
224 days which started on the 8th of
October 2022 to give for tired Russian
army the possibility to regain some
strength
124 days there was only Wagner guys
roaming the city
unlike kanoshenkov said it there was no
one to help us we only helped ourselves
let's get reaction then from Ukraine now
in our International correspondents Alex
Rossi is live in the eastern city of
danipra and Alex conflicting information
they're coming in from both sides how
much of this is propaganda from the
Wagner group
well it's really hard to say we can't
get there to confirm it ourselves inside
the city but effectively that the city
has been captured really by the Russians
for a number of weeks they've controlled
95 of it for a long time so
um even if it's is not true the city is
in you know the defense of the city is
looking pretty desperate we were along
the front lines around back moot
um this week and the soldiers there told
us really it was hanging by a thread it
was very very difficult to defend indeed
now in terms of the Russians if it has
fallen
um I suppose for them they can sell it
domestically to the Russian audience and
say well you know we're not getting
bogged down we are managing to to win
something but it really is something of
a symbolic Victory back moves itself is
a fairly small place it's a small City
I've been there many times since this
conflict started and it has taken them
11 months to capture it if indeed it has
finally Fallen to Wagner forces they've
also spent an enormous amount of
resource material
lots of soldiers Russian soldiers have
been killed there tens of thousands so
it is something of a pyrrhic uh Victory
so the other way of looking at it is is
what does it mean if it has fallen will
the battle in Ukraine change
significantly no it won't it's you know
it's a symbolic place the dynamism on
the battlefield will remain very much
the same Ukraine is also attacking along
the flanks of back moves as well it's
making uh inroads there I think all eyes
now really are on the counter-offensive
that Ukraine has expected to launch
shortly in the coming days that in
itself could could change things uh
dramatically it is of course a closely
guarded secret as to when it starts but
the expectation is they will try and
punch through Russian lines to the South